worse well that kind of goes in with our
next story actually oh yeah yeah we
should get into that so I will I will
add one more thing though I think
patreon is worse because they know what
they're doing they choose to do it but
that brings us to the next story
artificial intelligence will do what we
ask and that's a problem yeah
do you wanna I mean this was you you
wanted say bye-bye teaching machines to
understand our true desires one
scientist hopes to avoid the potentially
disastrous consequence of having them do
what we command so like a literal
command like make me a sandwich and the
robot tries to turn you into a sandwich
you know or like a werewolf bar or
whatever that is yeah but it's the
danger of having artificial intelligent
machines do our bidding is that we might
not be careful enough about what we wish
for the lines of code that animate these
machines will inevitably lack nuance
forget to spell out the caveats and end
up giving AI systems goals and
incentives that don't align with our
true preferences and that is scary I
have I have real real proof do you yeah
go ahead let's hear it this I love this
store ATS why I love this subject you
see once upon a time YouTube back in
2013 item meeting mmm-hmm and they said
to me we want to be Netflix
oh yes and they're trying to become that
they're trying to be bigger than HBO and
Netflix yeah I said they said something
like our competition isn't Facebook or
and like that it's Netflix and I and I
was like why do you think that and they
were right when Netflix digital came up
people stopped watching YouTube and
started watching binging premium
dimension flicks yeah so here's what
ends up happening YouTube tried doing
YouTube originals let's pay creators
like PewDiePie and Matt Pat to make
shows okay kind of worked not what they
wanted didn't they have like a YouTube
TV thing going on from yes they still do
okay so here's what ends up happening
though yeah yeah the other idea they had
was how can we turn YouTube into Netflix
I got it algorithmic manipulation that's
here they talked about this right here
let me tell the story I'll see how it
fits because it gets crazy okay
so YouTube did something interesting
they said we want to prioritize content
longer than
ten minutes okay we want high retention
time and what they were thinking was if
that's what you Netflix has will copy
the metrics of Netflix and prioritize it
in our algorithm and guess what they got
children's music singing while Hitler
danced and did kung-fu with the
Incredible Hulk while a dude sang into a
$2.00 headset instead of a microphone
and vocal it sounds like that oh my
goodness
you can google these things and you can
see these videos I'm not kidding so what
ended up happening was the algorithms
gave YouTube exactly what they asked for
exactly the retention time was so high
because babies can't change the channel
that's why it was Nursery Rhymes they
used keywords that were shocking and
enticing and exciting yeah so the
Incredible Hulk spider-man Elsa Hitler
whatever skeleton engine worked and so
they found the holes in the algorithm
and the YouTube algorithm turned around
and gave them everything they asked for
they thought they asked for Game of
Thrones and they got the Incredible Hulk
doing Tai Chi with a skeleton in a
bikini singing nursery rhymes and that's
what's scary about this those videos are
still up you can google them I talked
about this ID it's creepy stuff it's
funny though it's really funny I show
people all the time they're like feh but
here's what's really crazy like hey look
it's scarier we we're adults so when we
see this freaky video we're like I know
that's insane yeah but what if you're a
baby you think it's normal what about
when these systems do the exact same
thing with adult content
you can't tell is crazy so what ended up
happening was Facebook prioritized you
know content that got clicked the most
guess what ended up happening there was
a website that did nothing but police
brutality videos okay I became a global
top 400 website like one of the biggest
websites in the world making millions of
dollars because these videos got clicks
by shocking people you know Facebook
asked for engaging content and it drove
people into political madness where they
lived in a world where every day they
saw 10 videos of police brutality and
they thought the whole system was like
evil cops marching like all cops must be
you
then yeah this is always easy and they
believe it yeah and it's partly why
everything's gone nuts politically yeah
because while we can look to the videos
from the bait but the babies watched and
say that's nuts
the adults can't tell the difference
when they get you know real-world
content and it's you know smashed in
their face here's let's start let me
read this it says here it says the most
alarming example is one that affects
billions of people YouTube's aiming to
maximize viewing time deploys AI base
content recommendation algorithms so two
years ago computer scientists and users
began noticing that you YouTube's
algorithms seem to achieve its goal by
recommend increasingly extreme and
conspiratorial content one research
reported the after she viewed footage of
Donald Trump campaign rallies YouTube
next offered her videos featuring white
supremacist rants Holocaust denials and
other disturbing content the algorithms
upping the ante approach went beyond
politics she said videos about veganism
led to videos about or about
vegetarianism led to videos about
veganism videos about jogging led to
videos about running ultra marathons and
as a result research suggests YouTube's
algorithm has been helping polarize and
radicalize people and spread
misinformation just to keep us watching
if I were planning things out I would
probably not have made the first test
case of how we're going to roll out this
technology as a massive scale says Dylan
Hadfield you know and then nay a
researcher at the University of
California Berkeley and guess what man
that's all fake
is it yep yep I've done this many so I
know you you you know all about this
stuff first let me ask you a question
how does YouTube know the dip how does
the algorithm know the difference
between vegetarian and vegan that's a
good point
I don't know did YouTube a program you
know exclude word animal product exclude
word milk did the algorithm yeah I don't
know I don't get it but so it does kind
of make sense though it's like kinda
make sense though yeah yeah Sophia so
here's what ended up happening there was
more recent Reacher's have been done on
this because all of these new the news
outlets started claiming that there was
a radicalization engine right basically
what this would be okay
so if veget a vegetarian leaves to leave
to veganism have you ever seen a my
favor example have you ever seen a
Superman cultist no like a bunch of
people dress up like Superman and go
around chanting you know like you know
truth justice and the American Way over
and over again no but I kind of wanted
to be a thing but why not why why edit
the thing but why does one thing lead to
extremism but you don't end up seeing
like you know some of the biggest
content is video games yeah you see
people dressing up in like full destiny
costumes running around thinking they're
actually no it's all Minecraft and for
tonight where the Minecraft extremists
there why is the most prominent content
not radicalizing people it's because
what ends up happening is the latest
research on this so first it's for as
important to say there is a problem with
the AI that YouTube is programmed okay
it's not radicalizing people it's
creating weird content yeah okay that
makes more sense so what you end up
seeing is not radicalization you end up
seeing the Incredible Hulk ants with a
skeleton yeah we're a research show
hitting the clips that what really
happened and this is this is what's
really funny is that YouTube recommends
halt what I find hilarious is that you
ever you ever see somebody post on
social media where they're like stop
sending me you know ads for gay porn no
so like it's a common meme where someone
will be like I can't believe these ads
are popping up on Facebook and people
are like those are targeted ads to
people who are are gay you know they
mean like so okay I showing a targeted
ad they're revealing that they were
targeted for a reason the YouTube
algorithm doesn't understand the content
of radicalization if you search for
Donald Trump you're just as likely to
get Trump sucks or Trump's awesome you
have to be chose which one you want to
watch but you're also just as likely to
get votes nope rally wouldn't it just
roll don't don't they just roll over to
the next video like it'll continue
playing yeah on the next Auto yeah
whatever yeah how do you how do you know
random oh it's so listen is it how does
YouTube know the difference between
someone saying good things about
immigration and bad things about
immigration
great question I don't know they don't
so how does it make sense that you do
YouTube could radicalize you if a
progressive is gonna say immigration is
good and something to immigration is bad
well YouTube has to autoplay one of
those videos if more people are clicking
out there in the world that immigration
is bad then don't
wouldn't that algorithm assume that
that's the more like viewed
that's what they'll suggest potentially
yeah but what ends actually ends up
happening is the autoplay is random
based on keywords and like retention
rates and things like that mm-hmm
so one what actually ended up happening
was there are certain people with
certain views that are ostracized by the
mainstream so they found a place to talk
about what they care about on YouTube
creating a large pool that branches off
into its own unique space oka these
activists who work in media who are
subject to the exact same algorithmic
problems are confused as to why when
they watch videos about Trump they start
seeing a bunch of things they don't like
yeah but it's because they're clicking
on them right the actual latest research
out of Penn State and Berkeley shows you
have to choose you have to choose the
audience member has to decide they want
to because even with the autoplay they
got rid of all all this by the way they
actually so actually what's happening
now as YouTube literally did create a
polarization engine this is what's
really funny this is the backfire of the
AI in response to fake news written by
these news organizations about how a I
was radicalizing people and it's not
true okay YouTube then changed it so
that people would be pushed to MSNBC or
Fox News and that literally started
radicalizing people so there are
progressive channels yeah and they're
pushed to Fox News how does it make
socks as progressive no no exactly
that's the point you could be a
progressive more like a politically
neutral individual yeah yeah who watches
a political video and then they start
putting Fox News all down your throat
and so I've actually complained about
this I'm like why is it that you know I
have a moderate opinion yeah you would
send my audience members to Fox News
yeah that'd make like you've literally
in response to fake news about
radicalization engines created one but
because now they're literally pushing
everybody to one extreme or the other
now I got at Fox News and MSNBC are not
the extremes to a certain degree
but that's literally what ended up
happening so what this this is kind of
happening now it's kind of that innocent
right so the best example is Jimmy Dore
okay Jimmy Dore is I don't want to I'm
not saying it I don't want to you know
tell Jim it was Baltazar but he's a pro
Bernie okay pretty social I think is
socialist I'm not saying that you know I
think Jim is an awesome guy so if I'm
wrong Jimmy I'm sorry I didn't mean to
you know call you a socialist if you
weren't but if you were you know I don't
know
he's a Bernie supporter okay but he has
very similar opinions to me in terms of
like the establishment media and stuff
like that they're sending his viewers to
Fox News and that's actually it's I
would I would call that radicalization
but it's actually proof that YouTube
technically there isn't one do you think
Fox paid YouTube to get that to get the
newfound know ABC News got downtown
ranked so you're less likely to get sent
there okay and that for some reason I
think YouTube decided you know what all
politics how about we just make it all
go to Fox and MSNBC cuz no one ever
complains about them so I went through a
safer not really okay but the point is
if you make a video about the you know
Flat Earth or whatever yeah
then these these these journalists smear
YouTube and attack YouTube so then so
then YouTube says just send into Fox
News okay can't complain about that
that's been around for a couple decades
you know several decades same thing with
MSNBC but they're not talking about Flat
Earth their stuff no their mainstream
right so then the problem is they
blanket swept everyone up into this
algorithm to funnel everyone to Fox News
and MSNBC and that literally is
polarizing people yeah it's just so
insane men so anyway that what they're
suggesting has a fundamental flaw in it
right like I explained the AI does this
what they're missing though is the
algorithm isn't programmed to understand
that if the difference between veganism
and vegetarianism right those
differences are kind of subtle and
nuanced you know like does it have way
how would the algorithm know if the
candy bar you're eating actually had way
or had soy protein right exactly unless
someone explicitly said like like how is
it's possible it's entirely possible but
the problem always have with it is
whenever it comes to these extremists
they never talk about anything you know
in terms of actual what it really does
is gives you more of what you already
asked for if you ask for veganism you'll
get tons of veganism yeah it's true it's
it's it's so the this the other argument
should be the same why couldn't they say
if you search for vegetarianism you get
you get sent carnot arianism is there a
way you can set it so that it doesn't
remember anything you search I don't
know I don't think I would like that
because I
want I want the other side of the coin I
want to research and read all the papers
you know not just like the proven vegan
stuff like and not I don't even want to
talk about this stuff anymore but it's
you know I want to be able to cancel the
algorithm yeah yeah love that if there
was like a clean slate we need to do
that there was I'd have to make a new a
new YouTube account basically all right
incognito mode but even even that still
tracks like your IP data and stuff yeah
I'm sure there was a I think was a
Republican senator who proposed a law
that social media companies would be
forced to default you to an algorithm
less view of content doe that's great
yep thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you